Yes, yes!
Yes, welcome.
Thank you very much, great show tonight.
One of my favorites, JB Smoove,
gonna be on the program tonight.
He is always hilarious,
and that sound of one man
clapping, Andy Richter.
How are you, Andy?
Hi Conan, how are you?
I'm doing really well.
It's nice to see you
from this safe distance.
Yes, it is.
It's good, it's as per your contract.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Going back to 1993,
by the way.
That's correct.
This is the way I've wanted
it long, long before COVID.
How are you, old chum?
I'm good. How are you?
It's been a while.
It has been a while,
but I really love that
we're here in this theater.
I love being in a theater,
it just gives me the sense
that we're getting
closer to show business.
Yes.
You know, we're not really there yet,
but we're in a theater,
[Andy] Right.
and we're closer.
It's like Public Access.
Like it's not exactly
TV, but it is kind of TV.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna be honest with
you, that bummed me out.
Oh, I'm sorry.
That really bummed me out.
I'm sorry.
I mean, that's kind of what I do though.
I know, it's true.
Andy Richter, depressing
Conan since September of '93.
(Conan laughing)
Hey, speaking of, we
gotta talk about this.
Last night, I announced that I wanted
to fill my audience here
at the Largo Theater
with cardboard cutouts of fans,
just like Major League Baseball was doing.
So to get an idea of
what that would be like,
I had our prop department go into storage
at Warner Brothers, and find
every random cardboard cutout
they could find, and they
brought in the strangest
selection, but we put 'em in the audience.
We've got Ruth Bader Ginsburg right there.
We have Conrad Bain from,
"Diff'rent Strokes."
The dad on, "Diff'rent Strokes."
We have a life size, six foot six cutout
of former FBI director, James Comey.
I think he's either
taking the oath of office
or very formally trying
to catch a baseball.
I don't know what's happening there.
And then we've got four,
count 'em four Kevin Harts.
I think we bought those in bulk.
Andy, what do you think of
our audience right there?
I think it's great.
I love that, how they're
all to actual scale.
Here's what I have decided to do.
I want to fill the rest of the audience
with actual cardboard
cutouts of our real fans
who are watching at home.
That's right, you can be
sitting in my audience.
We'll make a cardboard cutout of you.
All you have to do is go
to TeamCoco.com/cutouts,
upload a photo of yourself,
and you may be able
to join our audience in
cardboard cutout form.
Isn't this a great idea, Andy?
It is a great idea.
Yeah.
I mean, we gotta
be making some money off it, right?
We're charging people,
like the baseball...
No, I didn't,
it's too late, I didn't think of that.
I should have thought
of a way to make this
into a money making scheme.
I didn't do that, this is free,
but if you send us your photos, listen,
people are already doing it.
We announced this yesterday,
already 5,000 people.
Wow.
Seriously, 5,000 people
have requested and sent in photos,
so keep sending those photos in.
You can be part of our audience,
and here's the other thing,
I would love it, if your
picture was laughing,
doesn't have to, I get it.
I've seen this show.
If you're not thrilled, you can, you know,
be frowning or maybe just checking
out a little bit, you know?
It's your decision on what kind
of photograph you want to have.
We want it to be realistic.
And I would say, Andy, you're
often scoping out the crowd.
A good third of the crowd,
usually not thrilled?
Yeah, well a lot of 'em
don't speak English.
They're here on like,
sort of like tour group.
I don't know how, it's like we get,
they're just, they're very easy to get.
Yes.
We give 'em a bottle
of water and an orange, and they're set.
(Conan laughing)
So, they laugh at the wrong spots.
We are technically a sanctuary show.
People come here for
sanctuary and immunity
from being deported.
Yes.
It's us
and, "The Price is Right."
We're the two shows that people flock to.
Yeah, you do not come on down on our show.
All right, seriously, you can do this.
Send us your photo and you
will be sitting in our audience
and you'll get to see
yourself, and that's all...
Yeah?
Can the photos be
clothing optional?
I think, I want to avoid legal trouble.
I'm gonna say the photos
should be clothing mandatory
for now, and then we
may, we'll see how long
this quarantine goes on.
Maybe the clothes will
come off at some point.
All right, yeah, 'cause we haven't
had nudes in the audience
since like early 90s.
'95 was the last one.
[Andy] Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
It was a hygiene thing.
It was a hygiene thing and yeah,
we had to steam clean the
seats, every, it was...
We, I did.
Well, you did, I can't,
I'm the host of the show.
[Andy] I know, I know.
You remember,
that was a big...
Big union thing.
[Conan] Big part of your job early on.
Yeah.